-Our next guest is a
Tony-nominated actress
and comedian, you know from
"Saturday Night Live" and movies
such as "Sisters,"
and "Wine Country."
Her podcast,
"Woo Woo with Rachel Dratch"
is available now.
She also stars in the animated
series "Grimsburg,"
which returns Sunday,
February 18th at 9:30 on Fox.
Let's take a look.
-Don't worry boy, son,
we're going to duct tape
this broken family back together
faster than you can say,
hereditary schizophrenia,
which you also
don't need to worry about
unless you're still seeing
your imaginary skeleton friend.
The one who made you pull
the fire alarm.
-Nope.
Therapy's working great.
Bye.
-He bought it, Stanley.
Now all we got to do
is make sure
he never talks
to your therapist.
Just like us.
-Mr. Flesch.
Now we can finally
start our plan
to get my parents back together.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our very good friend,
Rachel Dratch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Hi. Thank you.
Great to be here.
-I'm so happy to see you.
I got to see you a little bit
before the New Year.
-Yes. Oh, yes.
-Saw you at a party.
-Fancy party.
-Real fancy party.
-Very showbiz.
-Yeah, a lot of A-listers.
-Lot of A-listers.
-And then us. Yes.
-Yeah, we were there too.
-Yeah.
They kept saying,
"Can we show you to the B-list?"
-That's true. Yes.
-Can we find you a table
in B-list?
-Yes.
-Um, but you also, I heard --
Just do you think
it's in preparation
to maybe coming back
to 30 Rock
where you work, that you had
a you had an anxiety dream.
-Okay, so I knew
when I, you know,
I knew I was coming back
to see you.
And then that night,
I had a dream
that you and I
were getting married.
Okay. And -- And, like,
it was just very awkward
because we hadn't talked
about it at all.
And like, I was like,
are we going to text each other
about this or like.
And then we were supposed
to get married that night and --
and I was just I was
feeling awkward about it.
Not that you would make
a fantastic husband
and, but, there was
all sorts of things.
I was like, wait,
we didn't invite Lorne?
Like Lorne factored in,
as he always does
in an SNL anxiety dream.
And then I was like,
I didn't bring my shoes.
It was like every trope
you could imagine.
-So I like the crazier world.
As if Lorne had
an anxiety dream about you
and I getting married
and him not getting invited.
-I would love that.
I would love if Lorne had
an anxiety dream about me.
That would be amazing.
-If Lorne woke up
and just turned over,
he's like,
"I had the worst night.
I had a dream.
Rachel was mad at me."
[ Laughter ]
-I would love it. Please.
-Um, uh,
you have a new podcast?
-Yes.
-"Woo Woo."
-Okay. Yeah.
"Woo Woo with Rachel Dratch."
Now that's me.
Sorry, I didn't have to say
the name, but anyways.
But "Woo Woo" is -- Okay.
So over the years
I have collected like I love
when you're gathered
with friends
and then it turns to kind of
like ghost stories
and weird,
like psychic stuff.
And so then I was like,
why not do a podcast
where I talk to funny friends
about their weird stories?
-Because more funny friends
than you would think
have stories about real...
-Everyone has a weird ghost
except you.
-No.
-Because I did text Seth
to ask him
if he had any and he said no.
But you know what?
That's okay, because I still --
Like Amy Poehler came on.
She doesn't really believe so.
But then we found out,
oh, she's actually kind of
into crystals and she's in --
So everyone has some
sort of like, bent to --
Now don't quote me that
Amy Poehler is into crystals,
though, because...
-Why would we -- Why would
we quote you
when that's exactly
what you said?
[ Laughter ]
-What I mean is she's not
like super into crystals,
but she could veer
into the crystals.
-Probably not going
to make the article.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Amy's wind crystals.
Okay. By the way.
-You left out the worst
detail, which is you texted me,
"I have
a new podcast about ghosts.
Uh, do you have a story?
Would you want to come on?"
And I wrote back.
"I don't have a story,
but I'd love to come on.
-Right.
-And then I had to --
You didn't write me back.
-Okay, that's true, but...
-And so a week later, I was
like, well, now I have a story
about how my friend Rachel
ghosted me.
[ Laughs ] Oh, yes!
Yes, but I still want --
That was when
I was just getting organized.
I still -- I'm coming back
to you and I.
We can talk about whatever.
Like you can't even talk
about your disbelief in it.
Yeah. I love to
talk about my disbelief.
-I would love to have you on.
-Do you have one yourself?
-Yes.
So I have a ghost story
of my own.
This is embarrassing
because no one
wants to be the person
that sees ghosts.
But I did have
only one ghost story,
so I think that gives it
more credibility.
-Yeah.
-It was many years.
-No that's true.
If someone's like, I got tons.
You're like, all right.
[ Laughter ]
-And it happened at a hotel,
which a lot of ghost stories
happen at hotels.
But...
-'Cause they can't afford homes.
[ Laughter ]
-You're going to be great
on the show, kid.
[ Laughter ]
No. Um, no, but, uh, no, but --
So this is what's interesting.
My story happened to me, like,
you know, years like, well,
I guess now almost 15 years ago
or something like that.
But then years later,
I ran into someone who knew
the concierge at this hotel,
and I asked her,
like, is it haunted?
She said, yes.
She told me, people see things,
and people saw the same thing
that I saw.
-Really?
-Yes.
-What was --
What did your ghost look like?
-Well, here's
where I sound crazier.
But I saw two guys and they
were like, from another time.
They were dressed like
they were like early '50s.
And in my mind they were
a couple on the down low.
So I called them my gay ghost.
-Okay, but -- but --
but that wasn't me
trying to be funny and cute,
whatever.
That's just the vibe I got.
Like they were two guys
and they were a couple,
so I called...
-Okay, and did they --
Do you feel like they you
just observed them?
You did not feel
like they observed you?
-I don't know, maybe they were.
I don't know, I'm not sure.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know, but they were
friendly though.
They weren't scary.
-Okay. That's good.
And were you excited to hear,
like verification?
-Yes I was oh yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But that --
But that was way before.
Then I had the idea to do this.
And then that story
is in there at length.
But then I have, you know,
other friends,
like one friend has
an astral projection story.
Now I'm -- Now I'm fully nuts,
but astral projection story,
time travel.
-You have a friend
who time traveled?
-There's a crazy time
travel story in there. Yes.
-Do you want to say
who the friend was?
-Um, well, you don't --
you don't know her.
But if you listen,
then you'll hear.
-Do I know her
In the past?
-She was --Well, she was --
In a past life you do.
No, she was
a Chicago improviser person.
Oh, that's fantastic.
-Yeah. So I have, like,
you know, some celebrities,
some regular folks
I knew back in the day.
Yes. And that's "Woo Woo."
-That's "Woo Woo." The podcast.
Do you have --
Have you had other, uh,
other than your pair of ghosts?
Um.
Oh, by the way, congratulations.
A lot of people --
You only had the one sighting,
but you got two ghosts
on the same night, which is
pretty good.
-I got two.
-I'd feel bad if you have one
sighting.
-A Bogo situation.
-Um.
Have other things
happen in your life
that you feel like
are supernatural or?
-Well, yes, I had a --
[ Chuckles ] No. Okay.
Yes, I had a psychic tell me
that I was going to have a kid.
-Okay.
-But I was 43
when she told me that,
wasn't even dating anyone.
Blah blah blah.
Cut to, you know,
I have a kid.
-Yeah.
So the psychic was right.
-Psychic was right.
-When the psychic told you, did
you think the psychic was crazy?
-I was like come on, you say
that to every, like,
single lady walking in here.
-Yeah.
Was there anything else
they said that day that you,
when you had when Eli was born,
you're like,
oh, what else did she say?
Because it's all
going to come true.
-Um, I can't think of that.
-Yeah. Okay.
-I don't know.
That's all right.
-Yeah.
Cut that, cut that little.
-No, we don't do any cuts.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
Okay.
-Our editor doesn't.
Our editor is not back
till January 15th.
-Okay, shoot. Okay.
-Mark that down
is a slight lul, slight lul.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Definitely.
Mark it is slight lull.
-Mark it is as a slight lull.
Okay, okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-I like that you have a podcast
about ghosts,
and every time I've asked you
a follow up you're like,
"I don't know."
-Oh, I know,
I guess you're right.
-Hey, uh.
Oh, my God, I scared you.
-What?
-Um.
Ah!
-Ah! Ghost. Ghost!
What?
-You, uh, since I last saw you,
you were nominated
for a Tony Award.
Congratulations.
-Oh. Yes.
I was nominated
for a Tony.
Thank you. Yes.
-Very exciting.
-Yes.
Now, that was for a show
from last summer,
but let's still keep it going.
-Yeah, well, that's the thing.
Tony nominated.
Tony nominated,
forever.
-Wherever I walk in, like...
-yeah, you can. And you.
-I've here for my dry cleaning
and it's Tony nominated
Rachel Dratch. Yeah.
-Yeah, if you can't find it
maybe look under
Tony nominated Rachel Dratch.
-Yeah.
-Um, and you also we showed
a clip from "Grimsburg."
-Yes.
-You play a --
Jon Hamm is a --
-Jon Hamm is my dad.
And I'm his son.
-And do you do you enjoy it?
-All my best work,
playing male characters.
-Yeah.
-Um.
-Young male characters.
-Yeah.
-And Abe Scheinwald,
the old agent.
-That's the thing.
-You played the poles
very well.
-I've got a lot of range,
which is --
That's what you need
for the Tony.
[ Laughter ]
Um, okay. Um, yes.
"Grimsburg" and I play this kid
that's kind of, like,
really hoping is,
you know, kind of degenerate.
Dad is back in town, and I'm
just hoping for any attention
and that they get back together.
And it's kind of a sad
yet funny character.
-Um, I, uh, speaking of kids,
we mentioned backstage
and say me and my kids,
we walk to school
and we bump into you
every now and then.
-Yes, I Bump into Seth
with his kids
in the morning
when I'm walking my dog.
-And it's very exciting
because they --
You did a podcast
which came out a few years ago
called "The Cinnamon Bear,"
and I highly recommend it.
It's this wonderful, like,
20 part, uh, Christmas story
that we listen to when
we road trip over the holidays.
And so we've listened
to it every year.
And, uh, they introduce each,
uh, each episode says
who plays who.
And it was really exciting
because when we first time
we ran into you,
I said to my boys, I'm like,
This is Rachel Dratch
from "Cinnamon Bear."
And I was like,
who do you play again, Rachel?
And you were like,
"I have no idea."
[ Laughter ]
And my oldest son goes,
"Winnie the Stork."
And he fully knew your credit.
-He knew.
-And then you walked away.
And he was disappointed
that you didn't sound more like
Winnie the Stork.
-Uh.
But I thought that
you got home, and he said --
He said, like,
she sounds just like her.
Something like that.
-No.
-Okay, I ruined that.
Cut that lul.
-Cut that.
-Lul.
-I definitely want to cut
me getting a story wrong.
[ Laughter ]
-Mark that as the second lul.
-Okay.
-You know the best thing
about Tony
nominated actresses, though?
Even the lulls shine.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Um, yeah.
-Maybe the audience saw ghost.
-Maybe.
-Um, this is weird,
because we're done.
-Oh. We are?
-Yeah.
And it's hard to end
on a lull.
-We're done. Oh, shoot.
Okay, um.
[ Laughter ]
-We'll think of something.
Wait. Are we really done?
-Yeah, we're kind of done.
-Oh, okay.
-If you could see any kind of
ghost, what would you see?
-I got to end on a high note.
-Would you rather hear --
Would you rather
see a yeti or a mermaid?
-Ooh, a yeti.
-Really?
I would so much
rather see a mermaid.
Really?
Well, because I assume
in this story I'm in a boat
and the mermaid can't get me.
-Okay.
-But if you see a yeti.
So now you're in the woods
and you see a yeti.
What are you doing?
-Well, I'm picturing the yeti
from "Rudolph the Red-Nosed
Reindeer."
I'm picturing
Abominable Snowman.
-Okay, but that's still
a terrifying creature
before he gets
his dental surgery.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-You guys, that's Rachel Dratch.
"Grimsburg" returns
February 18th on Fox,
and her podcast "Woo Woo" with
Rachel Dratch is available now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night.